hello everyone and welcome back to some
more rapid action unleashes this is the
game I played in the previous video and
I've lost this one my opponent played
really well and I manage my time very
very poorly so I will do my best to
manage my time more properly uh in the
in the games to follow so let's uh fire
up another one 10 minutes per player uh
let's see if we can if we can uh you
know try to play good chest but also
play it a little bit faster so now we
got the black pieces and again we're
going to go for the hyperx rated Dragon
our opponent is J 98h yeah okay so he
captures he knows his
stuff uh so this is sort of the main
line that you have to know if you play
this and uh obviously he knows it uh now
now it's time uh now it's time to check
if I know it as well uh which uh okay so
he's still he's considering where to
retreat with the
queen he's going to go back now and
we're going to put our Knight to B6 so
so it's a
no okay so C4 is a novelty for
me uh Knight to C7 also possible yeah
because this he will just be able to
undermine it
later uh yeah
okay
H yeah okay let's see it let's see it
yeah of course he's going to go for this
as he does have now control of this
Square very
interesting very interesting what like
A4 no he he has to move the bishop
castle and we'll see what uh what
happens so it's uh you know as as usual
in the cilian everything is always
hanging it's
probably probably possible for for both
of us to blunder something in the first
10 moves especially now as this is
completely new ter for me I've never
encountered this line with Pawn to
C4 so we'll see what is
this um I'm checking if there's okay so
the E5 bone is sort of a the E5 bone is
sort of a huge bone in my throat and I
will have to figure out how to how to
take care of that and especially if he
get C5 in which I don't want to
see so probably even D5 isn't out of the
question yeah he's GNA prevent me from
from just continuing
the play what I want to play okay so the
bishop here obviously very strong he
wants to go for F6 that's how he's going
to defend so we have to block with the
bishop
here and I probably go Bishop to H6 yeah
no he's going to
capture okay very nice we might even
have a queen trade here if we if we want
a queen trade still deciding on that
because a check yeah if he trades I get
my knight here will'll have some threats
on C2 do nothing spectacular yeah of
course he doesn't allow
that but
uh how about how about how about a nice
Queen here move is that something no he
does have he wants to get here and then
have control of these two squares so not
particularly enjoying myself
here
let's go Queen
C5 because if he does this we do have a
check and then we pick up the pawn maybe
not really okay so he's going to go for
this
yeah yeah I would go for that as well
I'd go for that as
well so he wants to put his scary Knight
here to control these squares yes yeah
I've definitely messed something up here
so the C4 line is very
strong
huh
yeah not the best not the
best not the best he's he really has me
tied up here yeah Knight to
E4 this is
uh J
98h very very nice
maneuvering I don't know if he will rush
it yeah the queen is actually very
strong there because I can get a queen
trade if he goes for this right away and
then I'm also having some threats here
so now whose threats are
greater uh
he's telling me that uh his threats are
greater all right I don't really have uh
anything
better so he will just take and Castle
Queen side
obviously but no he can't as this is
this will also be hanging so I don't
know either he's uh really trying to get
more out of the position than it's
possible but I do like his position like
the E5 Pawn controlling everything the
Knight here it should be better by all
counts but we'll see what he makes of
it yeah really scary
stuff really scary stuff okay so he goes
here uh of course of course of course he
does yeah this is sort of completely
unplayable I will Castle even though I I
don't really gain anything by
castling
yeah and once uh once he gets C5 in it
will be it will take a miracle to
survive
this yeah King King
D2 quite a
move so I will have to
somehow
yeah this will take this will take a lot
so I have a I have a rook that I cannot
develop I have a bad Bishop my Knights
aren't really doing all that much so
we'll see okay so he's uh pretty
adventurous with his King I don't know
if I like that for
him not saying that the king here is bad
or anything but
uh yeah well he does have outposts
here can't really uh but putting a
knight on D6 Cho should just give him
really long-term advantage and
uh yeah maybe I could have left my king
on E7 so he can never play this because
I can just capture maybe that was the
way to
go I don't
know yeah so he stops anying checks here
that I might have
uh had and now it's time to figure out
how to how to play anything wow this is
incredible let's go King here sort of to
to prevent any future checks if
anything
if he goes here I can even consider an
F6 move shouldn't be a problem because
he doesn't have a dark Square
Bishop okay so he wants to stop
F6 at all cost which is uh which is
nice okay so we're going to shift our
Knight here so if he plays G5 at least
we get the F5
square and if not
if
not yeah I'm just playing a waiting game
here since I have no
moves I can just uh wait for him to
maybe overc commit or somehow misplay
his beautiful position but it's also
something that you have to try from some
from time to time well this is such an
ugly Light Square
Bishop yeah we're GNA play H5 here uh
simply uh because whatever he pushes I
want to push counter that like if he
goes here I'm going to go here if he
goes here I'm going to go here and even
with all of this I feel that uh yeah
scary tactics will be
possible all right so how do we how do
we get a move in where is where is our
move any
move have to play something disgusting
like Rook
B1 to get my knight to C7 and then maybe
to E8 and then maybe Advance the
pawn ah yeah something like that
definitely go
here yeah if he puts a knight here and
goes after my Bishop so he can collect
on D7 I can always block with the Rook
yeah he goes here okay we're going to go
here Knight
C7 and now if Knight D6 which is okay he
has a beautiful possession but it's it's
the key move that I have to defend
against I kind of feel like his Bishop
would be would would be much better
here if I pull this off Rook here Knight
here and and uh somehow at some point
get my Pawn up the board not now of
course he's defending it too many times
but if I pull this off this will be
nothing short of a
miracle
yeah and also he he has he actually has
time to activate this Knight because if
I go after the pawn he can play even F4
and then it's super
scary yeah luckily the Knight here will
not attack anything important he can't
go after my
Rooks yeah so he goes Knight here as
we've uh as we've already considered do
we
H we play A6 here do do we care about
Knight B5 yeah we kind of
do yeah this also also maybe
presents an opportunity of advancing B5
yeah if he doesn't go something like
this maybe even B5 is is an idea to gain
access to the to the to the D5 square
and now he's uh getting very low on time
yeah he knows he's better he knows his
position is beautiful and maybe just
maybe he will invest enough time to sort
of okay so is he looking for some
sacrifices
here like captures captures nah Knight
F6 maybe get some nah I don't think it's
possible Knight F6 to go after this
Pawn yeah everything looks good
here yeah now I'm now I'm sort of second
guessing B5 because maybe it's better to
just let him do all the work and spend
time yeah okay so he goes here as we've
uh as we knew he
would
uh
goes after the
bishop yeah let's get the Rook
here okay he goes after that and now
possibly it's it's time to execute B5 I
don't know if it has any actual use
now yeah my Rooks are disconnected this
is not not pleasant at all yeah okay so
he knew we were going to do
that
he has control over this Square now but
we are going to at least develop a
little bit yeah okay so he moves the
Knight and uh again not much not much
has been gained
here so we give up a
pawn and maybe
more yeah okay so we figured that pretty
much we pretty much figured that
okay now we're waiting for for a blunder
now we're waiting for a blunder or or an
overc commitment something since he
blocked the position he doesn't have F4
F5 it's covered many times so now we can
even activate the Knight somehow he has
to be mindful of the check because the
the pawn is pinned so it it doesn't do
all that much now okay so we're going to
play Rook here uh simply to have the
option of capturing if the Knight
moves playing a little bit faster okay
so he goes here what is The Rook doing
there
uh yeah let's go after the
pawn go after the pawn he's going to go
F4 uh let's create some threats not much
but let's create some
threats
this isn't even a threat I mean yeah
he's just going to play that let's go
back let's threaten a
fork yeah not even a threat let's go
let's go where yeah still go back we go
back have access to these squares again
play something weird he'll probably just
double up here to be ready to capture
here once the Knight
moves but then once the Knight moves we
do have a nice check Maybe
yeah he's down to 2 minutes so at least
uh we are for once playing on our
opponent's time yeah so he moves the
king all right let's go let's go again
here yeah we don't want to allow any
pawn pushes and we go we go here to
harass The Rook as the king Now sort of
took some squares from The Rook it's not
not much
but
okay okay he does have
that let's go here just to see what he
does because once he moves The Rook okay
so he's going to move
here yeah that makes sense that makes
sense let's go
here he has to somehow position his
Rooks to be able to push those
Pawns
yeah this is very annoying okay so he
goes here uh we go here once again now
threatening this
check yeah he goes back we go
here we go here we don't have anything
better maybe something like Rook B1 I
don't
know okay so we're still going to go
here I've got nothing I mean I'm just
asking him to find the move and
hopefully or overc commit yeah okay so
now he will double up he finds a way he
finds a way out of this
mess uh but we do have access to this
Square
now which he takes away from us okay but
now we go here and we have this again
somehow the night is coming into the
game yeah we're being very
annoying yeah okay so he allows it I
have nothing better I have to go for it
I have nothing better yeah do I even
capture this I mean I I give him the d f
file I'm thinking no yeah I'm thinking
no I don't even capture
this okay let's not threaten the pawn
here
uh let's go here he does have
C5 but I have check
he goes there
okay Mak
sense go for check create a past
Pawn this Pawn I will
take and uh yeah how do we how do we
advance from there's go to
B6 yeah no we can't we can or can we
yeah we can he's going to play that yeah
okay um not bad not
bad okay so he's down to 23 seconds do
we have anything meaningful
here uh doesn't appear so
yeah I have to take or do I no I have to
play this and allow him to
[Music]
take am I getting checkmated here am I
getting checkmated here that is the real
question
oh so he stops he stops it wow
beautiful beautiful did he find mate
yeah he found
mate is there a way to avoid it nah
there isn't there
is there is a way to avoid mate no there
isn't huh nice nice nice nice nice no
stal Matrix because I have the pawn no
nothing all right so good game yeah
maybe I should have tried stalling a
little bit longer uh but yeah he he he
found it uh but now let's let's check
what we did that was so terrible here
big congratulations to j98
H uh so let's just check real quickly so
this is fine yeah we know that up until
this point it is okay C4 like I said I
don't know B6 okay E6 so yeah so not E6
the the the thing is you have to go
D6 E6 uh creates holes in the dark
squares which is completely
anti-position here and Bishop G5 should
be met with Knight to D4
okay uh since I don't know that uh it's
hard to play yeah yeah and I should
trade Queens but still yeah already yeah
already this is lost for me so I managed
to to play uh play this but uh in the
end my opponent was able to Checkmate me
so yeah here we were holding on yeah
nothing spectacular here completely
winning for him and then at some
point the only thing we had was playing
on his
time but yeah still completely winning
completely winning I'm just interested
in yeah this still completely winning
yeah no the entire game yeah uh he he
was completely winning from uh from
start I just uh was able to make it a
little bit interesting because he had to
invest so much time but yeah here see
it's only only move six and already
completely blundering the position with
something like this six yeah I mean
incredible I've never seen the C4 move
and it uh baffled me completely that
I've
uh yeah now that I think about it I have
no idea why I played why I played E6
yeah
yeah this is uh not the way to go uh but
yeah like I said I'm not playing these
games to sort of uh annihilate my
opponents or to or to show you some some
sort of an opening trick or something
merely to give you an example of uh the
thought process that goes on at this
level when uh when playing U when
playing a rapid game that takes maybe
sometimes 20 minutes sometimes
25 uh you've seen that you can actually
defend for quite a long time and it was
uh you know it was give or take we we
lasted for 60 moves before we got
checkmated uh but we were already lost
on move what did I say uh we were
already yeah here after after d after
after E6 this should be considered uh
lost okay may maybe you can save it with
some brilliant play but yeah this is no
way to play chess uh but yeah so we
lasted from move 6 to move 60 with some
uh reasonable moves but it was E6 is
such a such a huge mistake that it was
impossible to recover and we are are
playing a high rated opponent so and
there you have it uh you know you you do
have to play play correct moves in the
opening if you want to have a chance of
at least reaching the middle game and to
play some sort of a um decent end game
uh so yeah once again really hope you
guys enjoyed it not the best day today I
got two losses but you know tomorrow is
a new day uh we'll see what happens and
I will Incorporated the C4 move into my
opening knowledge so next time hopefully
we do better uh so thank thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your
day